il il y a un point auquel je souscris
tout à fait dans ce que dit Hervé
Marseille c'est qu'au fond on n' pas
vraiment besoin d'une loi pour sur cette
question là donc cette volonté à tout
prix de légiférer sans cesse est une
volonté de posture poétique et moi ce
qui me marque quand vous lisez la loi
lisez juste les titres de chaque article
c'est une loi de peur relativement aux
étrangers c'est une loi de repli
pourquoi autant de tumultte autour de ce
fameux article 3 si on peut déjà
régulariser par d'autres VO notamment
par la voix de de la CC parce qu' unee
partie une partie du monde politique à
droite à l'extrême droite et une partie
de la majorité présidentielle mais
j'espère que ce n'est qu'une minorité a
des réactions de rejet vis-à-vis
d'étrangers qui sont présents sur notre
sol et qui ne posent aucun problème les
mêmes qui vont le soir au restaurant et
sont contents du repas qu' font ne vont
pas ouvrir la porte de la cuisine il
verraent derrière des étrangers qui font
la cuisine qui mène une vie paisible qui
se lève tôt le matin qui travaille tard
le soir et qui ne demande qu'une chose
c'est qu'on reconnaisse simplement ce
qu'il font dans notre pays et pour notre
pays et bien les mêmes prennent des
postures qui sont sur cet article 3 de
dire ah non on peut pas les régulariser
on va faire un appel d'air c'est faux on
sait que c'est faux ça n'existe Pasard j
est-ce qu'il y a une impasse politique
pour le gouvernement avec à la fois
l'elle gauche de la macronie qui tient à
cet article 3 les LR qui en font une
ligne rouge absolue les centristes qui
essayent de trouver un compromis entre
tout le monde il y a une impasse
politique pour géralde daranin vous le
pensez bah on verra bien s'il arrive à
s'en sortir mais il s'y est mis tout
seul enfin le gouvernement s'est mis
dans cet impasse il n'y avait absolument
aucune nécessité de légiférer sur cette
question et si vous regardez l'ensemble
du texte il ne il ne porte que des
points qui sont des points de rejet
d'étranger y compris vous savez quand
vous êtes étranger en France à force
suris il n'y a plus cet article 3 dans
le texte vous dites à force suris il n'y
a plus mais mais de toute façon vous
avez d'autres articles qui portent sur
les étrangers malades ou sur la carte
talent puisqu'on parlait de de santé ce
qui est tout à fait marquant c'est que
en fait on ne veut plus des étrangers
malades dans notre pays mais par contre
on veut prendre les médecins de des
pays du Sud enfin c'est on est un pays
qui se REP rejet des étrangers mais
c'est un texte de peur de repli et de
rejet et c'est absolument pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'est notre pays notre
pays change oui le monde change et
vouloir penser que on va revenir parce
que c'est ce qu'il y a derrière tout ça
se mêle avec évidemment le terrorisme
islamiste c'est ça qui est mêlé dans ce
texte quand vous lisez les amendements
que déposent nos certains collègues de
droite sur ce texte on voit le mélange
des thèmes et bien c'est un pays qui qui
a peur qui se replie et qui pense qui va
revenir aux années 50 ou mais maintenant
les années 50 pour pour venir en France
R mer c'est la Méditerranée c'était très
compliqué maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
simple mais retirer un titre de séjour à
une personne qui ne respecte pas les
valeurs de la République puisque je
crois que c'est ça qui est exactement
dans le texte à l'article 10 ça c'est du
c'est du bon sens
non le respect des valeurs la public
c'est ce qu'on peut attendre d'une
personne mais bien sûr mais après il
faut le définir précisément et quand je
vous dis mais il y a quelques
dispositions dans ce texte qui sont tout
à fait acceptables hein je vous ne dis
pas que la philosophie mais la
philosophie du texte est détestable et
vous parlez de de ne pas respecter
valeurs de la République j'ai lu des
amendements qui proposent de retirer les
titres de séjour ou de ne pas accepter
de régulariser quelqu'un qui a commis
une faute mineure que vous moi tout le
monde peut connaître voilà donc on est
on est bien dans une lecture politique
qui est très très très une lecture de
peur qui est destinée probablement à
satisfaire ou à empêcher l'extrême
droite de se développer je ne sais pas
où ça en est mais toujours est-il que
nous nous combattons fermement cette
ligne parce qu'elle n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce qui'est la France alors on
voit bien que ce sera compliqué pour le
gouvernement en tout cas le débat n'a
pas encore commencé est-ce que si les
choses sont mal engagées pour le
gouvernement vous pensez qu'il peut
recourir à un nouveau
493 il sera précieux celui-là puisqu'on
est plus dans le débat budgétaire donc
il grille une cartouche la se oui la
seule de la session je je pense que
utiliser la procédure du 493
c'est-à-dire empêcher le Parlement de
libéré au fond sur une question aussi
importante pas pour dire que le budget
n'est pas important mais sur une
question sociétalement aussi importante
sera un formidable aveux d'échec pour le
gouvernement c'est que il n'est pas en
situation de faire comprendre et de
faire partager sa ligne politique par ne
serait-ce que sa propre majorité parce
que c'est ça que ça signifiera on voit
bien que la majorité présidentielle
elle-même est divisé sur ce texte donc
il se sera mis lui-même dans l'échec et
ce sera un échec sur l'échec
[Musique]
rapidement